planarian is a flatworm it has one head
and one tail normally and the amazing
the several amazing things about
planaria but basically they kind of I
think I think planaria hold uh the
answer to pretty much every deep
question of life for one thing they're
similar to our ancestors so they have
true symmetry they have a true brain
they're not like earthworms they're you
know they're much more advanced life
form they have lots of different
internal organs but they're these little
um they're about you know maybe two
centimeters in in the centimeter to two
in size
they have a head and a tail and the
first thing is plenary are Immortal so
they do not age there's no such thing as
an old planarian so that right there
tells you that these theories of
thermodynamic limitations of on lifespan
are wrong it's not it's not that well
over time of everything degrades no
planaria can keep it going for uh
probably you know how long have they've
been around 400 million years right so
these are the actual so the plenary in
our lab are actually in physical
continuity with plenary that we're here
400 million years ago so there's
planaria that have lived that long
essentially what does it mean physical
continuity because because what they do
is they split in half the way they
reproduce is they split in half so so
the planarian the back the back end
grabs the petri dish the front end takes
off and then they rip themselves in half
but is isn't in some sense where
like you are a physical continuation Yes
except that except that we go through a
bottleneck of one cell which is the egg
they do not I mean they can there's
certain planaria goddess so we go
through a very uh ruthless compression
process and they don't yes like an auto
encoder you know sort of squashed down
to one cell and then back out these
these guys just tear themselves in half
and then each and then and so the other
amazing thing about them is they
regenerate so you can cut them into
pieces the record is I think 276 or
something like that by Thomas Hunt
Morgan uh and each piece regrows a
perfect little worm they know exactly
every piece knows exactly what's missing
what needs to happen uh in fact in fact
if you chop it in half as it grows the
other half uh the original the original
tissue shrinks so that when the new tiny
head shows up they're proportional so it
keeps it keeps perfect proportion if you
if you starve them they shrink if you
feed them again they expand they their
control their anatomical control is is
just insane somebody cut them into over
200 pieces yeah yeah Thomas Hunt Morgan
did hashtag science yeah amazing yeah
and maybe more I mean they didn't have
antibiotics back then I bet he lost some
due to infection I bet I bet it's
actually more than that you could I bet
you could do more than that humans can
do that
because well yeah yes I mean again true
I accept that you can at the embryonic
Club well that's that's the thing right
so so I tell when I talk about this I
said just remember that is as amazing as
it is to grow a whole planarian from a
tiny fragment half of the human
population can grow full body from one
cell right so so development is really
you can look at development as a as a
just an example of regeneration yeah to
think we'll talk about regenerative
medicine but there's some sense what
would be like that warm in like 500
years where I can just go
regrow hand yep I with we're given time
it takes time to grow large things but
for now yeah I think so I think you can
probably why not accelerate oh biology
takes his time I'm not going to say
anything is impossible but I don't know
of a way to accelerate these processes I
think it's possible I think we are going
to be regenerative but I don't know of a
way to make it fast if you just think
people from a few centuries from now be
like well they have to they used to have
to wait a week for the hand to regrow
it's like when the microwave was
invented you can you can toast your
um what's that called when you put a
cheese on a toast
um
foreign
eria why were we talking about the
magical planaria that they have the
Mystery of Life yeah so the reason we're
talking about plenary is not only are
they Immortal okay not only do they
regenerate every part of the body uh
they do they generally don't get cancer
right so which we can talk about why
that's important they're smart they can
learn things so you can train them and
it turns out that if you train a
planarian and then cut their heads off
the tail will regenerate a brand new
brain that still remembers the original
information do they have a biological
Network going on or no yes so their
somatic cells are forming a network and
that's that's what you mean by true
brain what's the requirement for a true
brain I like everything else it's a
Continuum but but a true brain has
certain characteristics as far as the
density like a localized density of
neuronsa guides behavior in the head
exactly exactly if you cut their head
off uh the the tail doesn't have that
doesn't do anything it just sits there
until the new brain is is you know until
a new brain regenerates they have all
the same neurotransmitters that you and
I have but here's why here's what we're
talking about them in this in this
context so here's your planar you cut
off the head you cut off the tail you
have a middle fragment that middle
fragment has to make one head and one
tail how does it know how many of each
to make and where do they go how come it
doesn't switch how come right
so so we did a very simple uh thing and
we said okay let's let's make the
hypothesis that there's a somatic
electrical Network that remembers the
correct pattern and then what it's doing
is is recalling that memory and building
to that pattern so what we did was we
used a um a way to visualize electrical
activity in these cells right it's a
it's a it's a variant of what people use
to look for electricity in the brain and
we saw that it has a that that fragment
has a very very particular electrical
pattern you can literally see it once
once we developed a technique it has a
very particular electrical pattern that
shows you where the head and the tail
goes right you can you can just see it
and then we said okay well now let's
test the idea that that's a memory that
actually controls where the head and the
tail goes let's change that pattern so
basically incept a false memory and so
what you can do is you can do that in
many different ways one way is with
drugs the target ion channels to say and
so you pick these drugs and you say okay
I'm going to do it so that instead of so
that instead of this one head one tail
electrical pattern you have a two-headed
pattern right you're just editing the
electrical information in the in the
network when you do that guess what the
cells build they build a two-headed worm
and the coolest thing about it now no
genetic changes so we haven't touched
the genome The genome is totally wild
type but the amazing thing about it is
that when you take these two-headed
animals and you cut them into pieces
again
some of those pieces will continue to
make two-headed animals
so so that information that that memory
that that electrical circuit not only
does it hold the information for how
many heads not only does it use that
information to tell the cells what to do
to regenerate but it stores it once
you've reset it it keeps and we can go
back we can take a two-headed animal and
put it back to one-headed so now imagine
so there's a couple of interesting
things here that um that have
implications for understanding what web
genomes and things like that imagine I
take this two-headed animal
um oh and by the way when they reproduce
when they tear themselves in half you
still get two-headed animals so imagine
they take them I throw them in the
Charles River over here so 100 years
later some scientists come along and
they scoop up some samples and they go
oh there's a single headed form and a
two-headed form wow a speciation event
cool let's sequence The genome and see
why what happened the genomes are
identical there's nothing wrong with the
genome so if you ask the question how
does so so this goes back to your very
first question is where do body plants
come from right how does the planarian
know how many heads it's supposed to
have now it's interesting because you
could say DNA but what hap what what as
it turns out the DNA produces a piece of
of Hardware that by default
says one head the way that when you turn
on a calculator by default it's a zero
every single time right when you turn it
on just a zero but it's a programmable
calculator as it turns out so once
you've changed that next time it won't
say zero it'll say something else and
the same thing here so you can make you
can make one headed two-headed you can
make no headed worms we've done some
other things along these lines some
other really weird constructs
so so this this is this this question
all right so again it's really important
the the hardware software distinction is
really important because the hardware is
essential because without proper
Hardware you're never going to get to
the right physiology of having that
memory but once you have it it doesn't
fully determine what the information is
going to be you can have other
information in there and it's
reprogrammable by us by bacteria by
various parasites probably
um things like that the other amazing
thing about these planarias think about
this most animals when we get a mutation
in our bodies our children don't inherit
it right so you can go on you could run
around for 50 60 years getting mutations
your children don't have those mutations
because we go through the egg stage
planaria tear themselves in half and
that's how they reproduce so for 400
million years they keep every mutation
that they've had that doesn't kill the
cell that it's in so when you look at
these planaria their bodies are what's
called mixoploid meaning that every cell
might have a different number of
chromosomes they look like a tumor if
you look at the the the the the the the
the the the genome is an incredible mess
because they accumulate all this stuff
and yet the the their body structure is
they are the best regenerators on the
planet their Anatomy is Rock Solid even
though their genome is all kinds of crap
so this is uh kind of a scandal right
that you know when we learn that well
you know what are genomes or what
genomes determine your body okay why is
the animal with the worst genome have
the best anatomical control the most
cancer resistant the most regenerative
right really we're just beginning to
start to understand this um relationship
between the genomically determined
hardware and and by the way just as a as
of a couple of months ago I think I now
somewhat understand why this is but it's
really it's really a major you know a
major puzzle I mean that really throws a
wrench into the whole
nature versus nurture
because you usually associate
electricity within with the nurture
and the hardware with the nature and
it's there's just this weird integrated
mess yeah that propagates to Generations
yeah it's much more fluid it's much more
complex
um you can you can imagine what's what's
happening here is just imagine the
evolution of a of an animal like this
that multi-skillers goes back to this
multi-scale competency right imagine
that you have two two you have an animal
that um that where it's its tissues have
some degree of multi-scale Competency so
for example if the like like we saw in
the tadpole you know if you put an eye
on its tail they can still see out of
that eye right that you know there's all
this incredible plasticity so if you
have an animal and it comes up for
selection and uh the fitness is quite
good
Evolution doesn't know whether the
fitness is good because the genome was
awesome or because the genome was kind
of junky but but the competency made up
for it right and things kind of ended up
good so what that means is that the more
competency you have the harder it is for
selection to pick the best genomes it
hides information right and so that
means that uh so so what happens you
know Evolution starts basically starts
although start all the hard work is
being done to increase the competency
because it's harder and harder to see
the genomes and so I think in planaria
what happened is that there's this
runaway phenomenon where all the effort
went into the algorithm such that we
know you got a crappy genome we can't
keep we can't clean up the genome we
can't keep track of it so what what's
going to happen is what survives are the
algorithms that can create a great worm
no matter what the genome is so
everything went into the algorithm and
which which of course then reduces the
pressure on keeping a you know keeping a
clean genome so this idea of right and
different animals have this in different
to different levels but this idea of
putting energy into an algorithm that
does not over train on priors right it
can't assume I mean I think biology is
this way in general Evolution doesn't
take the past too seriously because it
makes these basically problem-solving
machines as opposed to like exactly what
you know to to deal with exactly what
happened last time yeah problem solving
versus memory recall so a little memory
but a lot of problem solved I think so
yeah in many cases yeah problem solving
yep
foreign
I mean it's incredible that those kinds
of systems are able to be constructed
um especially how much they contrast
with the way we build problem solving
systems in the AI world